when was the last time you saw a
bombastic pop punk r-rated girl gang
antihero Cape movie Margot Robbie and
company are on their way to deliver just
that here's what we know so far about
birds of prey and the fantabulous
emancipation of one harley quinn birds
of prey is set for release on February
7th 2020 cutting in ahead of the MCU
space for launch later in the year it's
a great soft release timeframe
traditionally speaking for movies that
have potential to be sleeper hits see
the first Kingsman film for how well
that strategy can work Marvel Studios
has released its own films this time of
year before so it appears to be mostly
luck that a much smaller budget film
like birds of prey isn't running up
against an MCU blockbuster that's a good
thing the film clearly deserves
attention given how many
first-of-its-kind decisions have gone
into its production and we're encouraged
to know it's release date is mostly
clear to really get that spotlight when
it matters most birds of prey is
headlined by a trio of women who live on
the edge between villain and antihero
unsurprisingly Margot Robbie will be
reprising her role as Harley Quinn from
2016 Suicide Squad
jurnee smollett val joins her as Black
Canary the high kickin sonic screaming
vigilante Mary Elizabeth Winstead will
play Huntress the daughter of murdered
mafia royalty and a peerless Archer the
supporting cast is equally intriguing
Rosie Perez will play detective Renee
Montoya a hardscrabble Gotham PD veteran
who became a fan favorite as an icon of
gay representation in comics and like
Harley Quinn first appeared in Batman
the Animated Series Ali Wong has been
cast in an unnamed supporting role as an
associate of Detective Montoya meanwhile
Ellijay Vasco will play Cassandra Cain
comic savvy people coming to the movie
will know Cassandra Cain eventually
becomes one of the several bad girls
under Batman's tutelage it's difficult
to tell at this juncture if the movie
will set her on the path to a bat career
but birds-of-prey screenwriter Christina
Hudson is also in charge of the Batgirl
script notably it does not appear that
Jared Leto will be reprising his joke
in any way whatsoever as the Clown
Prince himself would say I am NOT
someone who is
you and McGregor will be the major
antagonist of the film as black mask AKA
roman sionis a long time batman villain
like so many Batman villains he's a kind
of Dark Mirror to Bruce Wayne raised in
extreme wealth by industrialists parents
who never loved him and who also died
mysteriously he took over the family
business only to destroy it which led
Wayne Enterprises to purchase the
business out from under him consumed
with rage and a thirst for revenge he
turned to growing a crime syndicate
called the false facers and rose to
become one of the most prominent mob
bosses in Gotham City rumor has surfaced
that birds of prey will make a major
diversion in black mask's character to
portray him as a man who openly flirts
with secondary villain Victor Zsasz
Chris Messina best known for his role as
Danny Castellano in the Mindy project
has traded his boy next door rom-com
charm for a role so different that
describing it as polar opposites still
somewhat misses the mark Victor Zsasz as
a frequent inmate at Gotham's iconic
Arkham Asylum says is the ultimate
over-the-top presentation of a
nihilistic serial killer he marked scars
and his skin as tallies for each of his
kills and considers his murders to be a
gift liberating his victims from the
emptiness of existence based on the
trailer footage released so far it seems
like he will be working as black mask's
main Lackey chasing down the birds of
prey that is pretty consistent with the
character's role in the comics as zazz
is relatively straightforward violence
often makes him an excellent distraction
to be deployed by more cerebral Batman
villains
additionally Robert Katrina has been
cast as a character named stefano
Galante some have suggested that
Katrina's character may be a combination
of two characters from other Mafia
families prominent in Batman Canon
Stefano magic aura and jr. Galante the
Meldrick Ora family are chiefly
responsible for the murder of huntresses
mother suggesting that a whole lot of
potential character motivation is set to
unfold in birds of prey
Kathy Yin has been brought on as
director for birds of prey which makes
her the first Asian woman to direct a
superhero film
she began her professional life as a
reporter for The Wall Street Journal and
the LA Times before turning her eye to
film the result was a bridge between her
two careers with dead pigs a
fictionalized take on a guardian news
story about tens of thousands of dead
pigs found in the Huangpu River the film
was featured and lauded at the Sundance
Film Festival in 2018 John wick director
chads2 house key is serving as a second
unit director with a specific task of
expanding action sequences according to
The Hollywood Reporter's to hausky will
apparently be uncredited though fans
often see reshoots as a red flag there's
nothing too unusual at play here second
unit photography is a standard process
and Sahel Skees 8711 studio has been
assisting with birds of prey stunt
coordination from the beginning heavily
stylized in-your-face fighting sequences
are Sahel skis bread and butter so his
stylistic touch being added to what
already looks to be a bold visually
striking film is promising Cristina
Hudson coming off the surprise success
of the Transformers franchise's latest
offering bumblebee has written the
screenplay for birds of prey
Hudson must have developed quite a
kinship both with Margot Robbie and her
passion project as the two of them have
been chipping away at the screenplay for
three years
meeting Robbie and working on the
project took Hudson on what she called a
deep deep dive of DC Canon after growing
up as a Batman fan to say she's having a
great couple of years would be an
understatement
she's also been tapped to pen the
upcoming Batgirl script in the wake of
Joss Whedon's exit from the project
Hudson has been racking up accolades and
rapidly becoming the must-have
screenwriter of the industry with three
unproduced scripts on the blacklist
between 2012 and 2014 a rumored synopsis
in 2018 suggested that birds of prey
would find Harley Quinn breaking up with
the Joker and then teaming up with Black
Canary Huntress and Renee Montoya to
rescue a young Cassandra Kane from the
clutches of an evil crime lord at the
time of the original reporting Ewan
McGregor had not yet been cast and Black
Mask
even been publicly considered as a
character apparently the originally
intended big bad many drafts ago was the
penguin birds of prey comics are usually
serialized as vigilante missions so any
story to draw from them comes largely
through character backgrounds and
incidental moments as opposed to
overarching plot there's one bit of
rumored truly bizarre content floating
around the internet though without any
context it's both difficult to believe
or understand according to a couple of
alleged plot leaks the MacGuffin of the
film is rumored to be a collection of
nude pictures of black masks that
Cassandra Cain gets ahold of and then
eats to hide the evidence no that's not
all the pictures are somehow stored in a
diamond this is a rumor of course and
hopefully you will work better than it
sounds there's plenty we still don't
know about birds of prey but we
certainly know what it looks like
punkish irreverent and glitzy the first
teaser features the German house group
moderates his song a new error overripe
it cuts between the main characters
hanging out in costume hardly of course
is most eclectically dressed in
something like a yellow wrapper or
overalls and wearing a coat made of
holographic streamer material her
friends Black Canary and Huntress appear
in slick leather looking annoyed with
everything going on around them Victor
says without his usual visible scar
tallies and black mask smugly mug at the
camera it's more costume test than
trailer but it does just enough to hint
at the movie's vibe
the official birds of prey Instagram
announced a surprise trailer in early
October 20 19 in addition to four shiny
new posters featuring Harley when the
trailer went live online the next day we
were treated to a series of trailer
typical fast cuts of action mixed with
some establishing shots of all the
principal characters all dubbed over by
a monologue from Harley herself the
trailer is a relative feast compared to
the sneak peeks we'd had previously the
movies theme of emancipation isn't just
for Harley but for all the women on her
side united against black masks
Harley alludes to the fact that both she
and black Canary are Harlequins faceless
servants subject to master
Harley may be the star but it doesn't
seem like she's the only one trying to
carve out a new place for herself
Cassandra Cain is apparently on the run
from Black Mask and Victor Zsasz it's
unclear right now if Huntress is more
connected to Stefano Galante than black
mask but that's somewhat irrelevant as
the mobster is clearly working with him
Renee Montoya is introduced carrying a
box suggesting that she is either
quitting or has been fired from the
police force in short it's the kind of
wholesome story of sisterhood we can all
get behind a group of messy women drawn
together by fate to escape a monster
trying to catch them at New York
comic-con 2019 margot robbie gave an
interview to DC daily along with jurnee
smollett val Rosie Perez and Ellijay
Vasco in it characterization became
center focus with questions posed to
each woman about their place in the film
with emancipation being an overall theme
Perez talked about detective Montoya's
need to free herself from the
patriarchal oppression she experiences
in the police department of course
Montoya's character is more complex than
just feeling stifled as a police officer
she has a flaws too sometimes she will
do anything to you know make sure that
she meets her agenda it sounds like a
kind of chaotic good alignment justice
at any cost
Smollett Val described flat canary as a
person needing emancipation of the self
a woman who feels uncomfortable in her
own skin and specifically with her
powers her journey is about mastering
her ability and her identity in order to
find purpose Vasco says Cassandra Kane
is a street-smart take no guff girl who
is eminently capable of manipulation of
everyone around her friend or foe this
is a particular turn given the fact that
the plot summarizes her as needing
rescue she may be in danger but she's
clearly still determined to look out for
number one and Harlee according to
Robbie the story is told from Hartley's
point of view and that means color drama
and a wildly unreliable narrator but at
its heart this movie is guided by the
premise that women can save each other
catch birds of prey when it arrives
theaters on February 7th 2020 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]